uh fox's senior political analyst britt
welcome
the messaging from the white house was
supposed to be all donald trump
inaccurate trying to sell us
that the pandemic was over well we still
got a messaging problem from the white
house don't we
well we do when he's trying to blame the
uh lack of
uh full enough people being vaccinated
on facebook
facebook isn't responsible for that
facebook if anything has been kind of a
handmaiden of the white house and trying
to suppress
information that it facebook and the
white house don't like
and is now being invited to do so in a
more formal way certainly not fair to
blame it on facebook i think that the
messaging from the white house and other
health authorities throughout this
pandemic
which has turned out to be either wrong
or later contradicted
or and so on throughout this whole
season of the pandemic has left people
wondering what
what they can truly believe and i think
that is responsible in large measure for
the fact that
a lot of people are still reluctant to
get the shot you know you have people
who
don't like shots anyway um and then you
have people like robert f kennedy who
are anti-vaxxers
out there who are promoting this
information but i think
trying to blame facebook was a mistake
it's a huge mistake the dirty dozen
when they give them give us the rankings
as if we're all
uh sheep and don't make our own
decisions like if seniors don't know
that their seniors
or people compromised don't don't
they're compromised but i
digress the texas legislators who came
here
and looked at themselves as heroes and
chuck schumer looked up to him
teary-eyed
now find themselves overwhelmed by the
reality that they irresponsibly left
austin with no battle plan
and now find themselves the subject of
being covet 19
positive not warriors for a cause what's
your reaction
to how they stepped on their message
well the whole trip has turned into be a
complete fiasco
uh you know because leaving the
the legislature down there and depriving
it of a quorum
is interfering with the democratic
process in the state of texas
and what are they here to protest
alleged interference in the democratic
process because of the law
on voting and how it's to be conducted
that has been
passed by the the uh texas house and is
headed for the test by the texas senate
and is headed for the house
so to protest interference in the
democratic process they are
guess what interfering in a democratic
process and then they fly up here
and come down a bunch of them come down
with covid which is extremely
embarrassing so the whole trip i think
is just a total loss for them as a
as a political matter right uh speaking
of uh total loss every time the vice
president takes on a mission they seem
to be
raising eyebrows for example her latest
mission to get everyone vaccinated
she tapped into the bible let's listen
together
the very essence of what the bible tells
us when it says
love thy neighbor and in the face of
that stranger
you see a friend that's what this is
about
and so by getting vaccinated you are
loving your neighbor
now i get it what's your reaction to
reverend harris
well look if you want to get to get a
shot
on the theory that you won't be likely
to contract the disease and you'll be
unlikely to spread it and that's
and that's an act of generosity toward
your neighbor there's nothing wrong with
that
um it seems a little bit of a stretch
but uh you know my view of that is
uh love your neighbor is a good message
um brian there's something i'd like to
mention here
and that is that all of this discussion
now of people getting infected after
having the vaccines
is a little bit is a little bit needs a
little bit of perspective which is which
is simply this
we don't know how sick these people are
who are getting it
we don't know how how grave a threat it
is we hear you know 40 percent of
hospitalizations in britain are people
who are
actually we don't know how sick they are
um and
all along the reason for the extreme
measures that were taken
the shutdowns the closing of the schools
the constant merit
wearing of the masks and so all which
has done great collateral damage to our
country has been on the premise
that we're dealing with a deadly disease
i think the presence of the vaccine and
the fact that a great many people have
natural immunity occasion by the fact
that they had the vaccine and survived
it
has meant that this thing is simply not
the threat it once was
you know it's fun to talk about the
cases and how many there are and so on
but the fact of the matter is that this
this virus now
because of all that's happened is very
much less dangerous than it used to be
and let us pray brian that we don't
lapse back into lockdowns and
universal masking and all those things
that have been so difficult
yeah that's where we'll be the blame
because then we put idiots in charge and
that
has proven to be counterproductive that
means they don't learn from any of their
mistakes
britt you've been saying that all along
appreciate your perspective as usual
thanks so much
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else